nos quedamos en el problema número 8 así
que empecemos en el problema número 8
que dice lo siguiente la ganancia total
diaria en pesos
de producir y vender x unidades de
cierto producto está dada por la
siguiente función y dice px
pd x es exactamente igual a 17 x 17 x
menos a 10 x + b donde ven es una
constante sí nosotros sabemos que la
ganancia total de vender 300 piezas es
mil 900 pesos
es muy importante vamos a apuntar lo la
ganancia de vender 300 piezas esto es lo
mismo que mil 900 pesos entonces cuánto
vale la constante be ok pues es momento
de trabajar lo que hay que hacer es
sustituir a x
por 300 y nosotros sabemos que esta
ganancia es 1900 es decir si sustituimos
en p de x a la x por 300 vamos a obtener
17 por 317 por 300 menos
10 por 300 ya esto le vamos a sumar 20
que es justo lo que queremos y por
cierto esto es exactamente lo mismo que
esto es el dato que me dan la ganancia
que obtuve en pesos de vender 300
unidades de este producto fueron mil 900
pesos por lo tanto esto es lo mismo que
mil 900 pesos muy bien de aquí podemos
hacer algunas operaciones así que vamos
a trabajarlas a 300 por 17 3 por 7 21 y
llevamos 23 por 13 y 2 son cinco y 20 es
5 mil 100 5 mil 100 menos
aquí me queda 3000 menos 3.000 más ven
esto es igual a 1900 esto es igual a
1900 ok y ahora voy a distribuir este
menos este menos por este y este menos
por este y me va a quedar que 5100 5100
menos 3.000 menos 3000
- ven más por menos es menos ve esto es
igual a 1900 y vamos atrás ven por lo
tanto aquí me queda que 2100 2100 menos
ven esto es igual a 1900 a 1907 aquí
restó 2100 de ambos lados que me va a
quedar menos 2100 de este lado
y de este lado menos 2100 menos 2100
estos dos se van y me queda que menos b
es igual a 1900 menos 2100 éste es más
grande por 200 por lo tanto me va a
quedar menos 200 menos 200 o dicho de
otra manera si ahora paso este positivo
y este positivo me va a quedar que ven
es igual a 200 y este es el inciso en
que es la respuesta de este problema es
igual a 200 así que ya están empezamos
con el pie derecho utilizando un
problema en el cual tenemos una función
de x sustituyendo el valor de x y
obteniendo así
este problema estaba muy fácil y tenía
mucha aritmética y mucha álgebra que
utilizar pero bueno vamos al siguiente
problema borremos la pantalla vamos al
problema número 9 que me dice lo
siguiente el número que resulta de
multiplicar un entero por sí mismo el
número que resulta de multiplicar un
entero por sí mismo en qué números de
los siguientes incisos no puede acabar
ok esto está bastante interesante es un
problema donde hay que pensar mucho y
además es un problema muy importante si
nosotros tomamos cualquier número entero
y lo multiplicamos por sí mismo pues
esencialmente estamos obteniendo un
número al cuadrado un número al cuadrado
y este entero
n antes de elevarse al cuadrado puede
acabar en 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 o en cero
es decir que si nosotros ponemos aquí a
n y aquí hay n cuadrada y nosotros
decimos que n puede valer
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 0 que son todos los
últimos dígitos de cualquier número
entero entonces cuánto valdría n
cuadrada bueno pues 1 al cuadrado
acabaría en 1 2 al cuadrado acabaría el
4 acabaría el 4 3 al cuadrado acabarían
9 4 al cuadrado acabaría en 16 acabaría
en 6 en 16 le voy a poner aquí 5 al
cuadrado es 25 6 al cuadrado es 36 7 al
cuadrado es 49 8 al cuadrado es 64 9 al
cuadrado es 81 y 00 al cuadrado o 10 al
cuadrado acabaría en cero wow
si me dice todos los cuadrados de los
primeros números y bueno esto de que me
va a servir lo que quiero que veas es
que si esta tablita se cumple y estos
son los posibles valores que puede tomar
el último
dígitos de cualquier número entonces el
cuadrado de este entero el cuadrado de
cualquier número entero puede acabar en
1 o en 49 o en 6 o en 5 o en 0 vamos a
apuntar lo el último dígito del cuadrado
de cualquier número entero puede acabar
en 1 o en 49 esto ya está estricta o en
6 o en 5 este ya está este ya está éste
también esté también o en cero o en cero
estos son los únicos posibles valores
que puede tomar el último dígito de
cualquier número elevado al cuadrado y
por lo tanto si nos fijamos en los
incisos dice a uno a uno eso no puede
ser cierto porque podemos tomar el valor
de 194 eso tampoco es cierto porque
podemos tomar el valor de 465 tampoco es
cierto porque podemos tomar el valor de
5 por ejemplo 25 5 al 42 25
tampoco podemos acabar en sets por
ejemplo 36 16 y el inciso en dice 4 el
último dígito de cualquier número
elevado al cuadrado nunca acaba en 8 y 8
es mi respuesta porque ningún último
dígito de cualquier número entero
elevado al cuadrado va a acabar en orc
de lujo y hasta que el problema número 9
así que bueno pues vamos el problema
número 10 borremos esto y pensemos en el
problema número 10 y está de lujo porque
habla sobre canicas una bolsa contiene
solamente canicas rojas o amarillas o
azules
la probabilidad de sacar de manera
aleatoria una canica roja es de un
cuarto a esos importantes vamos a
utilizar el color rojo la probabilidad
de obtener una canica roja
es de un cuarto de un cuarto perfecto la
probabilidad de sacar de una manera
aleatoria una canica azul es de un sexto
utilizamos el color azul este me gusta
la probabilidad de obtener una canica de
color azul es de un sexto y nos
preguntan cuál de los siguientes valores
puede ser un número posible para la
cantidad de canicas totales adentro de
la bolsa ok me dan la probabilidad de
obtener una canica roja la probabilidad
de obtener una canica azul pero no me
dan la probabilidad de obtener una
canica amarilla creo que será muy bueno
de una vez sacarla la probabilidad de
obtener una canica amarilla le voy a
poner
jaime de amarilla a esto a cuánto va a
ser igual bueno pues si solamente
tenemos canicas rojas azules y amarillas
entonces la probabilidad de obtener una
canica amarilla es la restante o dicho
de otra manera esto es lo mismo que uno
menos un sexto menos un cuarto menos las
otras dos probabilidades y cuánto es
esto
bueno pues el factor común es 12 y me
quedaría 12 menos a 12 entre 62 por 12
menos 12 entre 4 estrés por una es tres
menos tres lo cual es un 12 menos 2 es
10 menos 13 77 12 a 27 200 y de hecho
creo que ya se me ocurrió una idea ya
casi tengo una solución que te parece si
escribimos la probabilidad de obtener
una canica azul también en 12 años es
decir esto es lo mismo que lo voy a
multiplicar por 2 arriba de 12 abajo me
va a quedar 2 sobre 12 2 sobre 12 y voy
a hacer lo mismo con las canicas rojas
si a esto lo multiplicamos por 3 arriba
y 3 abajo me va a quedar 3 sobre 12 es
decir la probabilidad de obtener una
canica roja es 3 sobre 12 la
probabilidad de obtener una canica azul
es 2 sobre 12 y la probabilidad por
tener
amarilla es 7 sobre 12 y lo estoy
escribiendo todo sobre 12 para tener un
denominador común dicho de otra manera
lo que estoy diciendo es que si nosotros
comparamos la razón entre las canicas
rojas y a esto entre las canicas azules
ya esto entre las canicas amarillas
entre las canicas amarillas pues bueno
esto va a ser igual am a como ya tenemos
el mismo denominador podemos hablar que
por cada tres rocas vamos a obtener dos
azules dos azules y vamos a obtener a su
vez siete amarillas siete amarillas
es decir que si nosotros metemos en una
bolsa 12 canicas tres de ellas tienen
que ser rojas dos azules y siete
amarillas para que obtengamos una
probabilidad de obtener una roja de un
cuarto una probabilidad de obtener un
azul de un sexto y una probabilidad de
obtener una amarilla de siete doceavos o
dicho otra manera lo que estoy buscando
es que para que nosotros tengamos
canicas en esta bolsa la cantidad de
canicas
tiene que ser un múltiplo de 12 esto es
muy importante tiene que ser un múltiplo
de 12 porque de otra forma no podríamos
obtener esta razón y bueno si tiene que
ser un múltiplo de 12 el inciso am no
funciona porque es 10 a 10 20 30 40 y 50
nunca es múltiplo de 12 a 10 no es por
el inciso b el inciso b dice 12 por lo
tanto las respuestas b 12 canicas 12 es
uno de los posibles valores que puede
tomar la cantidad de canicas totales de
la bolsa muy bien este este problema
además de ser muy colorido me gustó
bastante pero bueno es hora de pasar al
otro dejar de pensar en el pasado y
pasemos al problema número 11 así que
cambiemos de color problema número 11
dice cuando la suma de una lista de
precios está dividida por el promedio de
los precios de la lista el resultado es
camps increíble este problema está
increíble creo que lo primero que nos
es leer con mucha calma el problema y
entender que dice cuando la suma de una
lista de precios está dividida por el
promedio de los precios de la lista ok
ok ok nueva quedando más claro la suma
de la lista de los precios está dividida
por el promedio de los precios de esa
misma lista
el resultado es camps y nos preguntan
qué representa acá y bueno creo que lo
que se me ocurre es tomarme a tener
primero tres precios vamos a verla de
una forma particular y después vamos a
ver si lo podemos generalizar
imagínate que tengo solamente tres
precios el precio 1 le voy a poner el
precio 1 el precio
2 el precio 3 si tengo solamente 3
precios aquí tengo la suma de los
precios de esa lista y si esto lo divido
a esto lo voy a dividir entre el
promedio déjame cambiar de color cuando
hablo de promedio este me gusta entre el
promedio de estos tres precios de la
lista pues el promedio se saca sumando
estos mismos datos
uno más de dos más de tres
voy a sumar los tres precios y
dividiéndolo entre la cantidad de
precios que tengo 123 entre 3 el
resultado de esto es igual acá lo que me
preguntan es que representa acá y bueno
si te das cuenta esto es lo mismo que p1
p2 p3 dividido entre 1 está dividido
entre 1 y aquí tengo que uno más peor
más petra es dividido entre 3 y puedo
hacer una ley del sándwich este por este
entre este por este es decir me va a
quedar 3 que multiplica ap-1 más de 2
más de 3
esto a su vez dividido entre p 1 más de
2 más de 3 1 por esto pues es esto mismo
y si te das cuenta éste se puede con
este son exactamente iguales se pueden
cancelar y solamente me voy a quedar con
3 es decir que en este caso acá vale 3
que por cierto 3 es la cantidad de
precios que tenemos
de precios entonces creo que ya tengo
una idea intuitiva de qué es lo que vale
que la cantidad de precios o el número
de precios que tenemos vamos a ver si lo
podemos generalizar
y creo que no me va a caber así que
mejor déjame borrar esto déjame borrar
esto y vamos a generalizar lo volvemos
todo esto de aquí a esto no lo quiero y
esto tampoco y vamos a hablar de una
forma general supongamos que yo tengo n
precios me voy a tomar n precios
uy esto está interesante porque lo
estamos viendo de una forma general así
que vamos a verlo de una forma abstracta
estamos generalizando y vamos a tomarnos
amx.n precios entonces voy a sumar n
precios y me va a quedar el precio 1 más
el precio 2 más
así todos estos hasta llegar al precio
número n estoy sumando n precios aquí
tengo la suma de los n precios ya esto
me dicen que lo tengo que dividir entre
el promedio de estos n precios que es
pues el precio uno más el precio dos más
la suma de todos estos otra vez más el
precio en dividido entre la cantidad de
precios pero tengo 123 406 hasta n es
decir tengo n precios estoy dividiendo
esto entre n para encontrar el promedio
de estos n precios y ahora si utilicemos
la misma idea voy a dividir esto entre 1
y voy a hacer una ley del sándwich este
por este y éste por este y que me va a
quedar pues me va a quedar n n que
multiplica a este de aquí en el que
multiplica ap-1 más pedos más todos
estos hasta pn ya esto lo voy a dividir
entre 1 por estos que después
esencialmente estos de acá abajo pero no
más de dos más todos estos hasta
n ok y puedo eliminar estos con estos
muy bien y solamente me va a quedar en
el que por cierto pues me dicen que esto
es igual acá y entonces puedo concluir
que camps es el número de precios es
decir la cantidad de precios que tenemos
la cantidad de precios que vamos a sumar
o la cantidad de precios que tenemos en
la lista esto es que de lujo esta es mi
respuesta así que bueno pues aquí está
el problema número 11 creo que no estuvo
tan difícil pensarlo de una forma
general y todavía tengo el tiempo justo
un poco apretado pero justo para
intentar hacer el problema siguiente así
que borremos esta pantalla y vamos a
ponernos vamos ser el problema número a
el problema número 12 12 que tiene una
figura siguiente así que vamos a
apurarnos tengo primero un cuadrado un
cuadrado aquí adentro que es un cuadrado
punteado así que tomémonos la goma y
vamos a ponerle un poco para que parezca
que está punteado
un poco volvemos un poco volvemos un
poco volvemos un poco algo más o menos
como esto es un cuadrado punteado muy
bien y después tengo aquí unos ciertos
triángulos que me forman como una
estrella
tengo un triángulo así entre los dos por
acá un tramo de por aquí un triángulo
por acá después tengo por acá otro
triángulo por aquí y por aquí y otro por
acá por aquí y por acá y me dicen que el
área de este cuadrado que tengo aquí
adentro es de 81 centímetros cuadrados
si el área de este cuadrados de 88
centímetros cuadrados eso quiere decir
que cada uno de sus lados vale 9
centímetros 9 centímetros 9 centímetros
9 centímetros y aquí 9 centímetros ok si
me dicen que el área de cada uno de
estos triángulos de este triángulo de
aquí de este de aquí y de este de aquí y
de este de aquí de cada uno de ellos el
perímetro es 30
el perímetro de cada uno de los
triángulos es 30 y para que se vea bien
déjenme marcarlo con otro color el
perímetro de este triángulo que estoy
poniendo justo aquí el perímetro de este
es 30 lo que me preguntan es cuánto vale
el perímetro de la estrella de verde
bueno el perímetro de la estrella de
verde no está tan difícil porque fíjate
bien cuánto vale el perímetro de estos
cuatro triángulos si yo quisiera saber
el perímetro de estos cuatro triángulos
completos pues entonces el perímetro
quién sería sería treinta por cuatro
porque tengo cuatro triángulos el
perímetro de éste es 30 de estos 30 de
este también es 30 y de este también es
30 pero solamente quiero la parte que
está de verde no quiero en la parte que
está de rosa no quiero la parte de este
cuadrado que tengo aquí por lo tanto qué
te parece si a esto le quitamos
pues los lados de adentro es decir cada
uno de estos cuatro lados que cada uno
de ellos mide 9 centímetros
le voy a quitar 9 por 4 y cuánto es esto
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que 120
menos 36 menos 36 y cuánto es esto ya
para finalizar este problema y este
vídeo 120 menos 36 120 menos 36 es 100
menos 16 que es 90 menos 6 que es 84 la
respuesta de este problema es 84 el
perímetro de esta estrella de verde es
más déjame ponerlo de verde el perímetro
de esta estrella de verde de este lado
más este lado más este lado más este
lado más este lado más este lado más
este más este me da 84 centímetros 84
centímetros ya está así que ya se me
acabó el tiempo y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo